YOU NEVER KNOW.
THAT WILL SCARE PEOPLE.
>> Brian: EVERYONE ELSE’S.
>> Sean: WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
A LOT OF NEWS.
BIG NEW PROMISING DEVELOPMENTS
FROM AMERICA’S SEARCH FOR A
CORONAVIRUS VACCINE.
JUST HAD A TALK WITH A VERY
PROMINENT MEDICAL DOCTOR WHO IS
MORE THAN OPTIMISTIC.
WE WILL SHARE THIS GOOD NEWS
WITH YOU TONIGHT.
BUCKLE UP.
WE ARE NOW JUST 112 DAYS AWAY
WHAT HAS NOW MERGED INTO THE
SINGLE BIGGEST CHOICE ELECTION
IN MODERN AMERICAN HISTORY.
NOT AN EXAGGERATION, NOT
HYPERBOLE.
LOOK AT JOE’S TEAM.
IF JOE BIDEN WINS, HE HAS THE
STRENGTH AND STAMINA AND MENTAL
ALERTNESS TO DO THE JOB, IF HE
IMPLEMENTS THE EXTREME AGENDA
THAT HE’S NOW EMBRACING, LET ME
BE CLEAR.
AMERICA AS YOU KNOW IT, WE KNOW
IT, WILL BE DESTROYED.
OUR ENTIRE WAY OF LIFE WILL BE
FLUSHED DOWN THE DRAIN.
IF THE ISSUE OF LAW AND ORDER
SECURITY AND SAFETY, IF THAT
MATTERS TO YOU AND YOUR FAMILY,
CAPITALISM MATTERS TO YOU AND
YOUR FAMILY, IF OUR
CONSTITUTION, THE RULE OF LAW
MATTERS TO YOU, HERE’S WHAT YOU
NEED TO KNOW.
IN 112 DAYS YOU ARE THE ULTIMATE
JURY.
JOE BIDEN DOESN’T WELL REALLY
HAVE ANY ORIGINAL IDEAS.
HE NEVER HAS.
HE’S BEEN IN THE SWAMP 50 PLUS
YEARS.
50 YEARS OF ELECT ME AND I WILL
DO THIS.
I’LL DO THIS.
THE PRESIDENT SAYS ALL TALK TALK
TALK, NO ACTION.
SCHUMER, PELOSI, AND BIDEN
ALONE, 125 COMBINED YEARS OF
ELECT ME AND I’LL PROMISE THIS,
THIS, IN THIS.
NOTHING BUT 125 YEARS OF
MEANINGLESS PROMISES AN
UNMITIGATED FAILURE.
OH, AND ON BIDEN’S PART, LOTS OF
PLAGIARISM.
REMEMBER HE WAS ACCUSED OF
PLAGIARIZING A PAPER IN LAW
SCHOOL.
1980s.
MANY OF HIS SPEECHES WERE
PLAGIARIZED.
HE WAS ACCUSED OF PLAGIARIZING
ROBERT KENNEDY, HUBERT HUMPHREY,
BRITISH MP NEIL CONNECT.
WE PLAYED THAT FOR YOU LAST
WEEK.
THE SCARY PART IS BIDEN HAS
TAKEN HIS CUES FROM THE MOST
RADICAL, THE MOST EXTREME
SOCIALIST EXTREMIST THAT THIS
PARTY HAS EVER EMBRACED.
THE DEMOCRATIC MODERN SOCIALIST
PARTY.
LOOK AT THE CORRUPT FORGETFUL
JOE BIDEN TEAM.
YOU’VE GOT BIDEN, SCHUMER,
PELOSI.
THAT’S 125 YEARS OF WELL FAILURE
ALONE.
NOW ADD TO THAT BERNIE SANDERS.
CONGRESSWOMAN OCASIO-CORTEZ.
BETO, BOZO OR WORK.
HIS LATEST POLICY PROPOSALS WERE
LITERALLY AUTHORED BY THE DEVOUT
SOCIALIST BERNIE SANDERS.
NGO EVEN PLAGIARIZED BERNIE’S
AGENDA LITERALLY IN MANY
INSTANCES WORD FOR WORD RIGHT
OUT OF BOLSHEVIK BERNIE’S A
SOCIALIST PLATFORM.
BERNIE WANTS THE GOVERNMENT TO
CONTROL ALL MEANS OF PRODUCTION.
HE WANTS TO NATIONALIZE
INDUSTRIES LIKE THEY DID IN
VENEZUELA AND CUBA.
HE HAS PRAISE THOSE REGIMES.
BY THE WAY, HONEYMOON AND THE
FORMER SOVIET UNION.
MEANWHILE SOCIALIST
CONGRESSWOMAN OCASIO-CORTEZ,
SHE’S IN CHARGE OF BIDEN’S
CLIMATE TASK FORCE AND SHE WANTS
TO BAN OIL, GAS, COAL, AIR
TRAVEL, AND EVENTUALLY EVEN
COWS.
SAYS WE HAVE 12 YEARS AND IT’S
ALL OVER.
HER GREEN NEW DEAL WILL COST
$94 TRILLION OVER TEN YEARS.
THAT WILL TURN AMERICA INTO A
SOCIALIST BANKRUPT AND THEN
THERE IS BIDEN’S GUN-CONTROL
CZAR BETO BOZO ALL ROURKE WHOSE
TOP PRIORITY IS TO LITERALLY
TAKE YOUR GUNS AWAY.
THIS IS WHAT’S AT STAKE AND ON
HUNDRED 12 DAYS.
>> YES WE’RE GOING TO TAKE YOUR
AR-15, AK-47 --
>> GOING TO GUARANTEE THIS IS
NOT THE LAST YOU HAVE SEEN OF
THIS GUY.
WE WANT TO RECAP, BIDEN HAS
TAPPED BOLSHEVIK BURDEN, HE’S
PULLED PLAGIARIZING HIM.
AOC WILL LEAVE THE GREEN NEW
DEAL GREEN NEW TASK FORCE DEAL.
BETO BOZO IS COMING FOR YOUR
GUNS AND HE HAS SCHUMER AND
PELOSI IN CONGRESS.
THIS IS HIS TEAM?
GREAT THERE?
ADD BETO AND ADD AOC.
THEY WIN AND YOU CAN START
SINGING BYE-BYE MISS AMERICAN
PIE BECAUSE IT’S OVER.
WHAT’S NEXT, IS HE GOING TO
TAPPED LET’S SEE THE EVER
INCOMPETENT CUOMO.
IS HE GOING TO TAPPED COMRADE
de BLASIO AS HIS LAW AND ORDER
CZAR?
AFTER ALL, JUST LAST WEEK BIDEN
IN HIS OWN WORDS HE AGREED THAT
YES FUNDS SHOULD BE DIVERTED
AWAY FROM THE POLICE.
IN OTHER WORDS, HE’S EMBRACED
THE DEFUND THE POLICE MOVEMENT.
HE’S THE GUY THAT SAID LAST WEEK
POLICE HAVE NOW BECOME THE
ENEMY.
IN NEW YORK CITY, COMRADE
DE BLASIO, ALREADY SLASH THE
NYPD BUDGET BY A BILLION
DOLLARS.
HE HAS DISBANDED THE UNCOVERED,
THE MOST EFFECTIVE ANTI-CRIME
UNIT IN THE CITY.
HE HAS BANNED ALL STOP AND
FRISK.
NEW YORK GOVERNOR CUOMO WHILE
HE’S THE GENIUS THAT LET VIOLENT
CRIMINALS OUT OF JAIL WITH HIS
IDIOTIC $0 BAIL POLICY.
AS A RESULT, WE ARE SEEING
SHOOTINGS IN NEW YORK CITY AND
NEW YORK STATE, THEY ARE MORE
THAN DOUBLED OVER THE LAST YEAR.
ON MONDAY, AT LEAST 17 PEOPLE
SHOCKED, THAT INCLUDES THREE
DRIVE-BY SHOOTINGS.
AT ONE POINT OVER THE WEEKEND,
THERE WAS A SHOOTING EVERY
SINGLE HOUR.
LAST NIGHT, WE BROUGHT YOU
LAWRENCE JONES’ HEART HEART-WREN
INTERVIEW WITH THE FAMILY OF
THEIR 1-YEAR-OLD BABY BOY WHO
WAS SHOT AND KILLED IN A
STROLLER AND A PLAYGROUND IN
BROOKLYN.
THIS VIOLENCE IS UNACCEPTABLE.
IT COMES AS POLICE ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY NOW ARE UNDER ATTACK.
SINCE MAY, 12 POLICE OFFICERS
HAVE NOW BEEN KILLED IN THE LINE
OF DUTY.
TWO WERE MURDERED OVER THE
WEEKEND IN TEXAS WHILE
RESPONDING TO A DOMESTIC
DISTURBANCE CALL.
OVER 1,000 OTHER POLICE OFFICERS
SERIOUSLY INJURED, ROCKS,
BOTTLES, BRICKS, MOLOTOV
COCKTAILS, KNIVES AND GUNS BEING
USED AGAINST THEM.
THE CHAOS, THE CARNAGE IN
AMERICA’S BIG LIBERAL CITIES,
IT’S OUT OF CONTROL.
BY THE WAY, IF YOU WANT A
PREVIEW OF COMING ATTRACTIONS,
THAT WILL BE AMERICA WITH BIDEN,
PELOSI, AOC, SCHUMER, AND BETO.
THAT’S YOUR CHOICE.
WE CAN’T MAKE IT ANY MORE CLEAR.
YOU ARE THE ULTIMATE JURY.
SO DO YOU WANT IN 112 DAYS LAW
IN ORDER TO BE RESTORED OR DO
YOU WANTED TO GET WORSE?
BECAUSE BIDEN WANTS TO DEFUND
THE POLICE AND ABOLISH CASH BAIL
JUST LIKE THEY DID IN NEW YORK.
HE’S COME A LONG WAY FROM
CALLING PEOPLE PREDATORS AND YOU
KNOW SAYING UNDER INCENDIARY
THINGS ON RACIAL ISSUES LIKE HE
DIDN’T WANT HIS KIDS IN A
RACIAL JUNGLE IF WERE TALKING
ABOUT INTEGRATION.
HE USED THOSE WORDS.
LIKE I SAID AT THE TOP, THIS IS
NOW BECOME THE SINGLE BIGGEST
GREATEST JOYS ELECTION IN
OUR LIFETIME.
ON EVERY SINGLE IMPORTANT ISSUE
THAT WILL IMPACT YOUR KIDS, YOUR
LIFE, AND YOUR GRANDKIDS.
DO YOU WANT BIDEN’S PLANS FOR
OPEN BORDERS, FOR AMNESTY, THE
UNITED SANCTUARY STATES OF
AMERICA PUSH AND MARK THE MINUTE
YOU GET INTO AMERICA YOU GET
ABSOLUTELY FREE HEALTH CARE,
FREE FREE FREE, FREE SCHOOLS FOR
AMNESTY.
WHAT DO YOU PREFER, BORDER
SECURITY?
400400 MILES OF BORDER WALL WILL
BILLED BY ELECTION DAY.
DO YOU WANT BIDEN’S TAX
INCREASES OR DO YOU PREFER LOWER
TAXES THAT DONALD TRUMP IS
PROMISING?
DO YOU WANT BIDEN’S GREEN NEW
DEAL MADNESS OR PRESIDENT TRUMP,
LET’S SEE, HE’S MADE THIS
COUNTRY ENERGY INDEPENDENT FOR
THE FIRST TIME IN OVER 75 YEARS.
HE’S ALSO MADE IT FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN 75 YEARS WE ARE NOW THE
WORLD’S NUMBER ONE PRODUCER OF
ENERGY PURITY DO YOU WANT THAT
OR DO YOU WANT TO BAN: FRACKING
AND OIL PRODUCTION?
DO YOU WANT BIDEN’S ACTIVIST
JUDGES, LEGISLATING FOR THE
BENCH, DO YOU WANT TO STACK THE
COURTS LIKE WHILE DEMOCRATS HAVE
YOU PREFER CONSTITUTIONALIST, TH
THAT BELIEVE THAT’S THE
FUNDAMENTAL RULE OF LAW FOR
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
DO YOU WANT SOCIALIZED
HEALTH CARE?
DO YOU WANT TO KEEP YOUR PRIVATE
HOW DID OBAMACARE BIDEN CARE
WORK OUT FOR YOU?
DO YOU WANT HUNTER BIDEN MAKING
SKETCHY BILLION-DOLLAR DEALS
WITH THE BANK OF CHINA LINING
HIS OWN POCKETS OR DO YOU WANT A
PRESIDENT WHO WILL ACTUALLY
STAND UP TO CHINA AS THIS
PRESIDENT DID EARLIER TODAY?
DO YOU WANT ZERO EXPERIENCE
HUNTER MAKING MILLIONS MORE IN
UKRAINE?
QUID PRO QUO JOE, ZERO
EXPERIENCE HUNTER, OH, IT WORKED
OUT PERFECTLY, DIDN’T IT?
AS PRESIDENT FROM SAID TODAY
THERE’S NEVER BEEN A TIME WHEN
TWO CANIDS WERE SO DIFFERENT.
LET’S WATCH THE PRESIDENT.
>> PROBABLY NEVER BEEN A TIME
WHEN CANDIDATES ARE SO
DIFFERENT.
WE WANT LAW AND ORDER.
THEY DON’T WANT A LOT ORDER.
WE WANT STRONG CLOSED BORDERS
WITH PEOPLE ABLE TO COME IN
THROUGH MERIT, THROUGH A LEGAL
PROCESS.
THEY DON’T WANT TO HAVE ANY
BORDERS AT ALL.
THEY’RE GOING TO RIPPED ON THE
WALL.
IT WAS HARD TO GET THAT FILLED.
NOW IT’S ALMOST COMPLETED.
>> Sean: ULTIMATELY I’M ONLY
ONE VOTE.
MY VOTE IS PROBABLY NOT GOING TO
MEAN MUCH IN NEW YORK.
IT COMES DOWN TO YOU.
YOU THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
YOU ARE THE JURY HERE.
DO YOU WANT AMERICA TO BECOME A
PLACE WHERE WORKING HARD, DOING
THE RIGHT THING IS PUNISHED?
MOB RULE, ANARCHY IS REWARDED.
THAT’S WHAT BIDEN IS SELLING
WITH HIS TEAM OF PELOSI,
SCHUMER, AOC, BERNIE AND BOZO.
THOSE ARE THE STAKES IN THE 112
DAYS.
YOU ARE THE ULTIMATE JURY.
YOU GET TO SHOP THE WORLD AGAIN
AND YOU GET TO STOP WHAT THEY
WANT TO DO TO THIS COUNTRY FROM
HAPPENING.
YOU KNOW, IT WOULD CERTAINLY BE
WORTHWHILE JUST FOR THE PURE
ENTERTAINMENT PURPOSES TO WATCH
THE FAKE NEWS MEDIA MOB IN THE
COUNTRY, I’M JUST THINKING OUT
LOUD.
IN 112 DAYS, MAYBE EARLY TO 113
DAYS.
EARLY IN THE MORNING, HAVING TO
CHOKE ON THE WORDS WE CAN NOW
PROJECT THAT DONALD J. TRUMP HAS
BEEN REELECTED.
THE 45TH PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
HOW DO YOU THINK THAT’S GOING TO
GO OVER WHEN YOU GET THE CALL
AND WE GET TO WATCH THEM MAKE
THAT CALL?
THAT WOULD BE PRETTY AMAZING.
WE SURVIVED EIGHT YEARS OF
OBAMA.
I DON’T WANT TO GO BACK YOU KNOW
WHAT, AMERICA WAS RESILIENT.
THIS PLAN IS WAY BEYOND ANYTHING
THAT’S EVER BEEN PROPOSED.
THE MOST RADICAL, EXTREME
SOCIALIST PROPOSAL IN THE
HISTORY OF THIS COUNTRY.
IT WILL DESTROY THE U.S. FREEDOM
THAT HAS CREATED MORE WEALTH,
MORE OPPORTUNITY THAT WE HAVE
USED FOR HUMAN ADVANCEMENT
AROUND THE WORLD.
THAT’S ALL BECAUSE OF LIBERTY
AND FREEDOM.